iranian families
forced to flee their country to
different parts of the world including
right here in las vegas victoria saha
spoke to one mother who had just a few
hours to gather her belongings with her
daughters to escape she joins us now in
studio with this exclusive story
ukraine was the only home they ever knew
but life quickly changed forever for so
many ukrainians who had to leave but
escaping ukraine was just the start of
the many hurdles to come
it's my life ludmila inote emstiva shows
us the three small suitcases she had to
pack her life into we just
got in our car we only had six hours to
get ready and we left on february 24th
ludmila and her two daughters said
goodbye to the only home they knew in
venezia
i wasn't sure if my town will be
basically erased and bombed to the
ground she describes the long lines for
the gas station and atm as ukrainians
scrambled to get out we slept in a car
we act in a car four days on the road
led them to the polish border where she
had to say goodbye to her husband of 16
years he had to stay back and fight the
russian army it was ruthless
it's not something that
anybody can survive without getting
traumatized from poland they went to the
netherlands and then to las vegas where
ludmila is staying with her two
daughters thanks to a host family how
are you liking las vegas i
like it really
good as they try to adjust to life in
america there's a constant worry about
the husband and father that was left
behind yeah watching i'm always waking
up and going to sleep with it it's
it never stops that i
don't know when and if i'm going to see
my husband
ludmila and her family visited the
united states a few years ago their
10-year visa allowed them to come here
but it expires in september after which
she'll be applying for a refugee status
she is looking to get a car which would
allow her to hopefully start working her
daughters are 15 and 10 and in need of
summer athletic clothing since all they
were able to bring were their winter
clothes if you would like to donate we
have information up on our website at
8newsnow.com brian victoria